the Pope's astronomer and now it's not
your official title but it's a cook
title where does that come from I don't
know where people started using that in
the first place
Kings had astronomers in the past maybe
that might be what it's about it's a
shorthand way of saying that I'm not
just in an astronomer but I'm an
astronomer with an interesting position
with an interesting job being the
director of the observatory I'm only one
of a dozen astronomers but I'm the only
one that's directly appointed by the
Pope the real thing I think is to remind
people that astronomy is the kind of
thing you can't make a living at unless
you have a patron and in this case my
patron is the Pope and that shows the
world that the church is interested in
astronomy the nickname gives the
impression that the Pope would
occasionally consult you on astronomical
matters has it ever happened have you
ever got a phone call from a Pope saying
I was wondering about this or that the
closest that ever came was when a Pope
and I won't even be more specific than
that was going to be talking to
astronauts and you always have to have
some prepared statement and could I
prepare something for him to say or even
things that might be topics a tea you
know of course what happens with all of
these world leaders is that they meet so
many people day in and day out they
can't prepare their we talks ahead of
time so generally somebody says here are
some talking points and I did that once
when one of the popes was talking to
astronauts you've served under three
popes I believe what is your interaction
with popes and it's actually very
limited um you know we don't run into
each other in the hallway as a director
I'm part of the big audience every
Christmas with all the members of the
Curia where you have assigned seedings
and mice eaters in the back row off from
the quarter but you know I'm in the room
that's something that said the times
when I have interacted when I've been in
one of these audiences it's kind of
scary to say he knows who I am he knows
my name he knows my background and I
guess that means I can't hide but it's
also you know it's an honor
the three Pope's that you have served
under do they have any interest in
astronomy as far as you know do they
have much of a knowledge of astronomy um
it varied of course varies from Pope's
to Pope
the one that everybody can cite has had
a great interest in astronomy with spice
the 12th he was himself something of an
amateur astronomer and that would
sometimes get him into trouble as he
would make offhand comments about
astronomy that he had you know 90% right
and the 10% wrong then you have to go
it's actually like this I'll say of the
three that I worked with John Paul the
second was an academic and so he
appreciated academic work and the value
of academic work in and of itself on the
other hand the one time we showed him
images we had made of Comet
shoemaker-levy he sort of looked at him
and said ah bless you bless your comets
and that's about it
when Benedict came to visit he was full
of questions about the meteorites about
the work we did a very specific fuse and
is a brilliant brilliant man the other
thing that everyone is surprised about
Benedict he also has a wicked sense of
humor and he was able to give trade
jokes academic kinds of jokes about
orders of magnitude and things like that
which showed that he was definitely
following and knew what was going on
Francis has a background in chemistry
he'd worked in chemistry before he
became a Jesuit and as a Jesuit he's got
the academic background so he's
certainly well aware of what we're doing
the thing that I think shows the depth
of Francis was knowledge is let out of
see that encyclical he wrote which not
only gets the science right but he gets
what the science really is it's not just
a listing of facts it's not just uh this
is the mechanism what does it mean what
does it mean in a human sense what does
it mean to us who will always be a
little bit wrong but we're always
striving for the truth so it gets past
the absolutism of the science you
learned in high school where you know
you get the answer in the back of the
book and that's what science is well no
it isn't and he gets that why does the
Vatican have an astronomical observatory
there is a short answer and a long
answer and I'll give you something in
between really astronomy was one of
those things that you study did the
medieval universities along with GM
three and arithmetic and music and it
was a sense that you have to know how
the universe works before you can then
philosophize about it or do theology
about it one of the bizarre and
wonderful things about the people of the
book the Muslims the Jews the Christians
is that unlike a lot of religions we
think the physical universe was made by
God and therefore it's a good thing to
study you know the physical world is not
a morass that's designed to trap you
into evil chocolate is not there to lure
you into obesity chocolate is a
foretaste of the joy of heaven that's
released by theology and that means that
studying the physical universe in
particular cosmology or astronomy is
certainly a way of getting used to the
way that God works there is also the
practical side of things a lot of
festivals a lot of the Jewish holidays
and then from them the the Christian
holy days were based on the calendar
Easter was the first Sunday after
Passover Passover was based on the the
phase of the moon in the beginning of
the year that of course is why the
Pope's hired astronomers back in the
1580s to reform the calendar the modern
observatory dates from 1891 at that time
for the first time in almost a thousand
years the Vatican was faced with two
very different problems the idea that
somehow studying science studying the
physical universe was against religion
instead of in favor of it which was a
19th century idea and which was being
pushed by people who thought that you
know science is gonna solve all of our
problems steam engines and electricity
and eugenics oh Lord the church wanted
to say no that's not what science is
science is not against religion but
there are certainly bad things you can
do with technology technology is not the
same thing of science nobody doubts that
atomic bombs work because of fusion of
atomic particles because it doesn't mean
we can't argue about whether atomic
bombs are a good idea the other problem
the Vatican was faced with was that
after 1870 rather than having its own
independent nation in the center of
Italy it was reduced to just that area
around st. Peters
and the Italians didn't even recognize
him as an independent nation having a
national Observatory was a way of being
recognized as a nation so it had this
theological sense and it also had this
practical political sense by the time of
pius xi in the 1920s and 30s you find
statements where studying astronomy will
lead you to prayer and lead you to an
appreciation of God by the time you get
to john paul ii he sees
science and religion as equal partners
in the goal of looking for truth and
suddenly science has a very different
role than just being a useful tool what
Francis has done is to carry that one
step further and to recognize that
science is a human activity it's not the
universe it's how we humans try to
understand the universe and what that
does to us as humans you talk about
having an observatory being useful
because astronomy can help inform
theology but it sounds like you know the
Pope's not picking up the phone and
taking advantage of this resource that
they have here they don't have to have
you today
to inform their theology well then if it
seems like a resource they're not
utilizing if it was simply a one on one
connection that would be true but in
fact it's two communities talking to
each other it's the community of all
theologians as a community of all
scientists and we are along that
boundary there's you know a dozen of us
doing a dozen different things so that
under john paul ii for instance at his
insistence the Vatican Observatory began
a series of conferences on the nature of
divine action in the physical universe
so that we began this collaboration with
an institute in California called the
set of a theology and the Natural
Sciences published a bunch of deep
theological books that people are still
referencing a lot of the stuff that I do
is popularization
I'm standing up here with a Roman collar
and an MIT ring this is an MIT ring it's
not a bishops ring don't kiss it I write
articles for newspapers in Italy in
America in England and I show up on
things like this at the end of the day
by existing we remind the scientists
that religion is not their enemy even
more we remind the religious people that
science is not their enemy does that
mean this department of astronomers
that's here exists a lot because of
public relations it's like a PR move as
well public relations is basically all
of life my father was a public relations
man one of the founders of the public
relations Society of America I grew up
as a child knowing what public relations
really is it's important to have that
boundary that glue between the
institution that knows what it's trying
to do and the people who have a way that
they want to be able to refer to and
communicate with that institution and so
I'm very proud to say that's absolutely
what we're doing why astronomy why isn't
there a little math department or a
chemistry department or genetics why is
why does the Vatican have an astronomy
department first of all the Vatican is a
dinky place the entire annual budget of
the Vatican would pay for one-and-a-half
Hollywood movies a year it's not very
much and our budget is 1/2 of 1% of that
so there's not a whole lot of money to
do science historically there happened
to be astronomers available when they
thought they should have some kind of
national scientific institute and
national observatories were the sorts of
things that a government would support
cuz nobody else would there is this
inevitable gut connection between
studying the sky and studying things
outside of our mundane life and that
means that by being in this science we
can both explain why we're not really
studying this
because we're experts in both and we
know the difference but also to remind
us that we do astronomy just as we pray
for something bigger than to fill our
stomach for something bigger than to get
ourselves prestige that we're doing it
because we're hungry for something more
than what goes into our stomach because
we don't live by bread alone that's
literally true
I discovered that working in the Peace
Corps in Africa that people who were
hungry were also hungry for knowledge
were also hungry for respect we're
hungry for the opportunity to think and
feed their imaginations in their
knowledge surely you must see some
fundamental clashes between the very
underlying principles of science and the
very underlying principles of religion
like if you said to me Brady tell me
what religion is very quickly I'd start
talking about faith and a belief in
things that can't be seen or tested by
calls like electrons knowing that we
can't know because because black holes
even even when we can't see them we
refuse to believe they exist until we
see them and we spend a lifetime trying
to find proof of them an evidence of
them and image them we don't do that to
God like the aim of religion is not to
spend the next hundred years trying to
find evidence of God or image God or
find a horizon around him we have to
just accept he's there whereas science
is all about saying I will not accept
until I can test or look for it oh my
goodness what you've described is
exactly what religion is and what you've
described is exactly what science isn't
I'll give you three axioms every logical
system has to believe in axioms you have
to take as assumptions this is how the
world works before you can do logic
it'sit's girdle's theorem and to believe
in science you have to believe the
physical universe is real not every
religion believes that you know it's not
just illusion that there is actually an
underlying reality no matter how bad our
senses are you have to believe that it
obeys laws
who was the first person to think that
there were laws in science well what's
the alternative
oh the nature God's doing this and the
nature God's doing that but Christianity
doesn't take nature guts it says there
are laws and you have to believe it's
worth doing that studying the physical
universe even if it's not going to make
me rich is nonetheless a worthwhile
thing for grown-ups to do those are
axiomatic if you don't accept them you
won't be in an astronomer you have to
take those on faith likewise
religion only begins because you have
experienced what is for lack of a better
phrase a religious experience something
real happened whether it's holding a
newborn for the first time in your life
dealing with the death of a loved one or
just that walking down the street and
suddenly your out of nowhere hit and
overwhelmed with a feeling and emotion a
desire that you can't put your finger on
what that's about and then you say okay
how do I deal with this how are people
dealt with it in the past what works
what does it and just like science you
don't want to try to make it all up on
your own you don't want to have to
reinvent the wheel you want to find out
what has worked for other people in the
past an awful lot of religion only makes
sense as you get older and you
experience something and you go ah
that's what they were talking about but
the trouble is so many people stop
learning religion when they were 12 and
don't carry that into their the rest of
their lives just as too many people
stopped learning science when they were
12 and they think that science is
getting the answer in the back of the
book when it's anything but that it is
living with the mystery and continually
understanding it so that you go oh
that's what they mean by an electron I
never understood it that way before
science always comes up with better
descriptions knowing that better
descriptions yet are to come science
doesn't prove math proves science
doesn't science is not mathematics
and even the things that we've assumed
conservation of energy what's
fundamental to accept conservation of
energy doesn't work in atomic physics
and then you've got to kind of have
something else maybe being conserved and
likewise doubt is essential to religion
doubt is essential to faith the opposite
of faith isn't doubt the opposite of
faith is certainty so do you have any
doubt that God exists of course all the
time and I have worries about the
science that I do and I've got all of
these theories many of which I learned
from my professors gee is it just a
weird coincidence that my professors
were always right and the other
professors were wrong I'd better have
doubt about that because the goal
ultimately is to come to truth the goal
isn't to prove I was right because I
wasn't and I'm never gonna be right
science is a bunch of human invented
explanations for the physical universe
as human inventions I can always
understand them but they're always gonna
be a little bit short of the truth
religion our truths that I have to deal
with but that I will never completely
understand and if I ever think that it's
finished and it's done and it's all
packaged and it can be in a book it's
dead and that faith is dead and that
science is dead should humans be
striving for evidence of God's existence
no I think that's backwards what you
strive for is understanding the
experiences of life that we have and
there are different ways you can go
about with that understanding to me I
choose as one of my axioms that there is
a God underneath behind supporting all
of this and with that axiom I then try
to say what can I say about this God how
does that make sense of this universe
does this axiom work now if I come up
with a contradiction my answer is not to
throw away the axiom but to say I'm
about to learn something new
because to be honest I've never
encountered a moment where this bit of
science contradicted this bit of
religion but I have all the time run
into problems where this bit of science
contradicted this bit of science and
when the two bits of science don't agree
that I'm about to learn some new science
but isn't religion kind of designed to
avoid that collision with science well I
would also say the same science the
difference is that they are not
competing systems nor are they competing
books of facts where oh my gosh this
book says one thing in that book says
the other thing I've got to choose one
is truth seeking understanding and the
other is understanding seeking the truth
they're both dealing in the same playing
field but they're playing different
games can I ask you a personal question
then if you had to give up science or
religion you had to give one up which
would it be you say couldn't you can I
could not I could not be Who I am and
not any baby who's trying to figure out
where its toes are as a scientist in any
baby who is hoping that there will be a
meal or somebody to change its diaper if
already believing in something outside
of itself that it needs and forget about
feed and forget about diaper the need
for love you cannot be a human being
without having both and this this fury
Eights people when I say this when other
people say this but everyone has a
religion and everybody is a scientist
some of us are just really bad at it a
lot of scientists who I have met over
the years I would describe as atheists
and some I would even describe as being
quite hostile to religion you obviously
move in a lot of scientific circles you
know conferences and you know you're an
astronomer do you ever encounter
hostility took to being a representative
of the Vatican but also being a
representative of science yes not very
often the people who have been hostile
how can I put
have been wait elderly British males
it's this really narrow group of people
who I suspect were brought up with
really bad religion classes and you know
had a horrible experience when they were
14 and the religion they don't believe
in I don't believe in either what's
their angle of attack I haven't
encountered enough of them deeply enough
to be able to say that I could
generalize from that there are a couple
who I think maybe come from
stereotypically religious backgrounds
and want to break out of that stereotype
they want to say no I'm more than just
the evangelicals that I grew up with or
the whatever and so I can see that as a
sense of attempting to want to
assimilate into a larger culture a lot
of it is insecurity most fundamentalists
of religion or science are insecure you
have to have a certain arrogance to say
I don't know and I can live with that
but I'll tell you the other thing that
happened to me being in America and
being an astronomer
when I became a Jesuit I had already
been in the field 15 years everybody
knew me they didn't know I was Catholic
because not one of the things to talk
about and the most common reaction was I
didn't do you go to church let me tell
you about the church I go to
and I go I didn't know you were to
church either there's two of us
no tell I think in astronomy it's a lot
more common than other fields I think
biology is probably where you find the
largest number of atheists because the
biology is still in the 19th century
trying to find the gears and levers of
how life works I understand that what
people have told me is that the
proportion of people who identify as
atheists or believers isn't so much
whether you're a scientist or not of
scientist it's what culture you come
from what is your community where did
you grow up who are the people you grew
up with the fact is that you know
religious people have been doing science
and science was invented I've got a copy
here this is one of the volume
the Philosophical Transactions so i
pulled this one out it turns out to be
1816 he pulled it it ran to my Sawyer
opening page who are the people who are
publishing Sir Humphrey Davy Frederick
Herschel Humphrey Davy again
the Reverend Abram Robertson dee dee FRS
Doctor of Divinity and fellow the Royal
Society civilian professor of astronomy
at the University of Oxford and
Radcliffe Ian Observer you find if you
go looking through the Philosophical
Transactions or any of these other 17th
18th 19th century books about a quarter
of the people publishing scientific
works were the Reverend so-and-so who
else had the education in the free time
to do that kind of work and for that
matter what does a scientist do actually
day to day you collect data you sort
data you file data its clerical work
right why do they call it
clerical it was done by clerics do you
think there are any ways in which being
a religious person and a man of faith
gives you an advantage doing science via
the vatican gives me a tremendous
advantage I don't have to write grant
proposals oh my lord that's such an
advantage I can do long term research
projects that may take 10 or 15 years to
come to fruition but beyond that the
bigger advantage to me is it reminds me
why I'm doing it I'm not doing it to get
tenure I'm not doing it to show up the
guys at Arizona State I'm not doing it
to be rich or famous or any of those
other foolish things that would get in
the way of being willing to admit I was
wrong when I was wrong I'm doing it
ultimately because if I think that
science is a way of worshipping God then
it means I have to worship truth and
that has to mean that I know I don't
have the truth because otherwise why
would I be looking for it it has to mean
that I'm willing and desirous to hear
anybody else who has the truth whether I
like what school they went to or what
politics they have let me talk to you
about the G word Galileo
surely he is a millstone around your
neck working for the Vatican Oh think I
forgot Alejo if he wasn't around it
wouldn't have a job
because I have an interest in history
because I knew taking this job people
are gonna ask me about Galileo I get a
lot of reading I did a lot of research
not only the popular books but the
scientific works the story the true
history is fascinating and it's oh so
much more complicated and so much more
wonderful and basically everything you
know about Galileo is probably wrong it
doesn't make the church look any better
the church screwed up the Pope's screwed
up and the two important questions to
ask is how did they screw up and why did
they screw up and what can we learn from
that if you think it was because the
church was anti science then you're
missing the point that wasn't the
problem the problem was something else
maybe it was Pope's using the power of
the papacy for their own private revenge
some people think that I'm not sure that
maybe it was Galileo being tied up in
the politics did you know that the
Galileo trial occurred at the very
height of the 30 Years War which was the
first world war it involved every nation
in Europe it was a vicious and nasty and
horrible war and the Pope was under
phenomenal political pressures as was
Galileo's family supporting him and in
Florence is it just a coincidence that
Galileo who had been a friend of the
Pope and had been having great times
suddenly when all the battles started
going in a different direction found
himself in trouble maybe it was just a
coincidence
the written record only tells you half
the story as any historian can tell you
the stuff that everybody knows if they
don't have to write it down is the stuff
that we don't know anymore if there's
one thing that you like people
interested in this topic to know that
maybe they don't know what is it I would
love to get across the sense that
Galileo was very much a person of his
times he was not a 21st century
scientist trapped in the 17th century
and to understand
him and the pressures you have to know
he was living at the same time as
Cervantes writing Don Quixote
but at the same time as Shakespeare's
later plays at the same time as Goya
painting in strange new ways he was at a
time of revolution in thought and the
revolution hadn't finished it was still
ongoing and that's what makes him such a
wonderful person and someone for whom
the Catholic Church should well be proud
let me talk to you about another thing
the creation story are you glad that's
in the Bible yes yes and I'll tell you
why where did the creation story come
from the first chapter of Genesis where
was that written well you can get a hint
from the fact that the sort of cosmology
they're describing is Babylonian
cosmology even to the point where the
Babylonians had this myth that the gods
were at war and a dragon died and that
by accident created the universe the
name of the dragon in the Babylonian
myth is the name for chaos used in in
Genesis it's the same word so it's not
that Genesis is repeating the Babylonian
myth Genesis is assuming that whoever is
reading us has already heard the
Babylonian myth and what Genesis is
saying here is what's different from the
Babylonians what's different is that it
wasn't done by accident God deliberately
says what's different is that the God
who is saying that is already there in
the beginning in the beginning God the
difference is that rather than occurring
as a chaotic accident it occurs in a
logical step-by-step series of events
that can be reasoned out every step
along the way that God who is
responsible and chose to make this
happen says this is good and here's the
best part
the end and the point of the Babylonian
myth is to show that the city of Babylon
is the greatest thing that's ever going
to come along the pike that's not the
point of the Genesis story
where does the Genesis story end what is
the climax the ultimate goal of creation
it's not people that's the sixth day
it's the day of rest it's the seventh
day it's the day when we stop worrying
about how are we going to eat how are we
going to stay warm and instead we give
ourselves a day to think about the
bigger questions to think about who are
we where did we come from who loves us
what is the source of this love
what is this universe God created us to
be
astronomers you have this interpretation
of the Genesis story which is poetic or
insightful hmm a lot of people alive
today
don't have that interpretation they take
it more literally most of the people who
take it literally of the atheists who
use it as a reason not to believe in God
there are actually very darn few
literalist fundamentalists out there but
they seem to get all the press yeah it
happens so you think there aren't many
people who take it literally so doesn't
not only that it's again a sign of
fundamentalism it's a kind of
fundamentalism that's afraid to let go
of any bit of truth that I have because
they're afraid if they're wrong God
won't love them you know maybe I'm wrong
but God will still love me even though
I'm wrong why didn't God when he
inspired the writing of Scripture give a
more scientific truthful literal account
of what happened oh why didn't then why
didn't God inspire the Bible to say in
the beginning there was nothing except
me and then I did this and then over a
billion years this happened then over
another billion years this happened why
did he why did he make it seem so
fantastical not not that not that real
creation isn't fantastic over that
description would have seen fantastical
to anyone up to fifty years ago in that
description would seem primitive in a
thousand years there is no description
other than poetry that could pass
be timeless that's quite good answer
I'll give you that I remember that one
tell me about the observatory now tell
me about the type of science you're
doing here well if I think I've
mentioned before one of the great
advantages working at the Vatican is we
don't have to worry about grant
proposals I don't have to show results
after three years there also don't get
my job and that means the work that we
tend to do complements the work of our
colleagues everybody the observatories
got a PhD from a major university
someplace we've all got colleagues we've
worked with we've all got colleagues
that we're in a field that we're still
continuing to interact with I'm not
gonna do the kind of work that somebody
else is getting paid to do a lot better
than the more money I've got they've got
the better equipment they've got the the
bigger Department I'm gonna do the work
that I can do that supports the bigger
project in our meteorite lab we happen
to have more than a thousand samples of
meteorites a little bit of every type of
meteorite that's out there we are
measuring physical properties density
porosity magnetic susceptibility thermal
properties like heat capacity and just
making tables for how these vary among
the different types it's a work of 20
years not kind of almost like grunt work
but yeah absolutely grunt work and yet
great science comes out of it there's
been a question of trying to understand
stars in clusters soon after they're
formed in terms of their spectra
especially because the stars tend to be
in dusty parts of the galaxy and the
dust interferes with the colours
how can you see through the dust well
we've got people here who have worked
out using a series of very cleverly
chosen filters to be able to
characterize the type of a star
regardless of the dust that it's going
through it's taken them 20 years to work
that up they've got this system we're
now going in exploring embedded stellar
clusters to give us a better idea of
essentially the the census of the galaxy
where the star is being formed now how
we these stars different from stars
being formed elsewhere you can only do
that by a survey of lots of different
types of stuff
galaxies themselves interact they
collide with each other they orbit each
other one of our astronomers working
with colleagues in America has worked
out how the collision of galaxies around
the Andromeda galaxy can explain now the
stars that we see in the halo around the
galaxy and makes you realize that
galaxies are not closed systems galaxies
interact with each other they trade
stars a trade material this seems to be
a bigger theme of you know we have to
think the earth was a place until we
realized stuff is falling in on the
earth well the solar system is a place
now we're seeing interplanetary objects
hitting the solar system
well our galaxy is a place no we're
seeing interactions with other galaxies
the universe is not only a lot bigger
than we thought a hundred years ago but
it's not isolated every bit is
eventually chemically and physically
touching every other bit how much longer
I you the Pope's astronomer for in times
past you'd be astronomer for life and
that was much too long the director
before me made a rule a five-year term
you could renew it for five years my
first five years are up probably I'll
get another five years but by then I'll
be in my early 70s and it'll be time to
turn it over to somebody else what do
you hope to achieve before you finish
what's like how do you want this place
to be different or what would be what
would make you pleased with your tenure
what I want it to be and what I think
we've already got is a place where
people want to come and work where
people are happy doing the science
they're doing excited to get up in the
morning and go to the lab and if I can
accomplish that then I can be someone
who has made science fun it's real easy
for science to become just a job in a
pretty boring job and a perky you spend
most of your time staring at a computer
screen wondering what am i doing and you
know and you forget why you went into it
in the first place you forget the joy
that comes and if I can have the
observatory be a source of joy not only
to us but to our colleagues to remind
the other scientists that at the end of
the day we're in
for the love of it ultimately it's love
that makes these things move around
dartie had it right that's what I hope
we can be at the Vatican Observatory
make sure you also check out our tour of
the papal telescopes opening up with my
bare hands brother guy that videos on
our channel deep sky videos and over on
objectivity we'll be showing you the
Pope's and meteorites and this piece of
the Moon so there you have it people are
scientifically boring piece of moon rock
all sorts of interesting things in the
Vatican observatories collection there
are links on the screen and of course in
the video description